[Music]
alright Joe Biden's campaign is an
all-out damage control tonight Biden
incorporated they have now been exposed
in spite of the media mobs lying and the
cloud of corruption darkens above Joe
303 300 and his family shady dealings we
also have big bombshell news that the
media doesn't want you to know
remember Biden is now in very hot water
over what are credible claims that in
fact and he's on tape bragging about it
leveraging your tax dollars 1 billion of
them in your money to get a Ukrainian
prosecutor fired why would a
vice-president United States want a
prosecutor and Ukraine fired why because
he was investigating his son and even
the New York Times tipped him off thanks
to National Review Online they have an
incredibly detailed timeline of what
preceded this blatant quid pro quo these
are the facts now we could go back as
far as 2007 it would take the full hour
but let's go back we will start on
December 4th 2013 hunter Biden joined
his father Air Force two takes a trip to
Asia they stopped in China where his
father at a meeting with the Chinese
president and his son was having
business meetings then in December 2013
literally less than two weeks later
hunter Biden's company inked a 1 billion
dollar private equity deal with a
subsidiary of the Chinese government's
Bank of China as Peter Switzer pointed
out in secret empires this was a deal
unlike any other Western firm got it
went to hunter Biden who had virtually
no experience or expertise in China or
private equity can ask yourself why
would hunter Biden get such a sweetheart
deal a billion dollars then it became a
billion five you know we got break
they've great big companies you know big
names like Goldman Sachs or Deutsche
Bank or why they choose hunter Biden
what a area of expertise did he bring to
the table that they didn't have what did
he have to offer beyond being the son of
America's second most powerful
decision-maker now we'll fast forward to
December 2014 Joe Biden appointed the
point person for the Obama
administration in Ukraine he was in
control
the Ukrainian portfolio that's right in
control of directing all Western aid
dollars into Ukraine like a billion of
them and then a few months later April
2014 well Joe Biden's son hunter scored
a lucrative position on the board of
Purisima holdings
that's the Ukrainian were Ukrainian
energy oil gas giant again hunter Biden
it was paid a lot of money now this time
not billions but this time millions of
dollars and again he had no experience
in oil gas energy or with the country of
Ukraine a great gig in November of 2015
Joe Biden was advised by the New York
Times his son Hunter was under
investigation by Ukrainian authorities
in December 2015 Joe Biden made his
first request to the president of
Ukraine please fire the prosecutor
that's leading the corruption
investigation into my son and Maurice
Moe Holdings and in March 2016 John
Solomon reporting right here on this
show Biden knew this prosecutor was
investigating it's Sun and getting
awfully close to bringing him in for
questioning
that's when Biden leveraged as we have
on tape the billion dollars in aid and
forced the Ukrainian president to fire
the prosecutor and as Joe 303 306 hours
or you're not getting the billion guess
what son of a B they fired him
prosecutors signed an affidavit we
showed you this earlier under the threat
of perjury that he was told this was the
reason for his firing also he told John
Solomon ABC News and the Washington Post
the same thing and while sleepy creepy
crazy Uncle Joe spins in a million
directions trying to convince voters he
knew nothing about any of his son
dealings all these little inconvenient
picture as arisen that would be of Joe
Biden hunter Biden golfing with well
hunters partner Devin Archer in 2014
member Archer he was also on the board
of verissimo holdings and worked at
Rosemont Seneca with hunter Biden that's
the China deal this photo was taken just
months after hunter Biden teamed up with
Purisima Holdings Media is lying to you
and saying no there's no evidence really
this was Donald Trump jr. there would be
a ton of evidence so where's the
scrutiny of all this where's the serious
investigate
reporting I've reported on this show
journalism in America died it's dead
since o7 and probably way before now
profiting off the by name is not
anything new it's been going on a long
long time it was an August peace tin
political magazine they got it right
twice I got to give them big props
tonight and that detailed how in 2006
hunter and Joe's younger brother James
they took over a firm called paradigm
Global Advisors
they apparently sought to use their
father's influence to line their own
pockets their brothers influence they
didn't even try to hide it because that
piece quotes an executive at the company
said the following about Joe 303 3 oz j
--m z
don't worry about investors don't worry
about that we got people all around the
world they want to invest in Joe Biden
he was chorus now yeah important person
in government more boasting quote James
Biden made it clear he viewed the fund
as a way to take money from rich
foreigners who could not legally give
money to his older brother or his
campaign account
we've got investors lined up in a line
of 747s filled with cash ready to invest
in this company the executive quotes
James Biden is saying now can you
imagine to stop for a moment with all we
just told you what if the person was
Donald Trump jr. Eric Trump heck Ivanka
Baron Trump imagine how much the mob and
the media would be obsessed with that
story does that prove my point
journalism is dead you know exactly what
they'd be doing and they wouldn't be
covering for Don junior they'd be
Fanning the flames
remember this is stereo over the Trump
Tower meeting it had nothing to do with
Russia collusion that didn't stop them
their lies their smears theirs Manjit
slander their besmirched aunt there's
speculation they're breathless
hysterical reporting we do have good
news the media mob despite of what
they're trying to do they're doing us a
huge favor because we've known a lot of
this for a long time and it's now
boomeranging back on to Biden and a
shakedown of US taxpayer money that he
used to get the Ukrainian prosecutor
investigating his son fire and you know
and I know in the America
was smart enough to know if the names
were reversed that's all your media mob
would be talking about after three years
of Lies smearing disbursement conspiracy
theories and a hoax they haven't learned
a thing